what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some exciting news as
the first picture for Joker 2 Foley Adu
has been released showing us the Joker
himself played by Joaquin Phoenix and
Lady Gaga playing psychiatrist harleen
quinzel AKA Harley Quinn now we did get
a brief teaser for this film back in
August but it was just kind of
Silhouettes dancing so not really a true
first look but today we do have our true
first look now obviously we are no
stranger to Joaquin Phoenix's Joker the
first Joker movie was fantastic but now
in Joker 2 Lady Gaga joins him as the
iconic Harley Quinn now for the most
part this basically just looks like a
picture of Lady Gaga with the joker and
keep in mind that this story is most
likely about how the two of them meet
and how harleen quinzel actually becomes
Harley Quinn so the first Joker film was
the origin of what we have now as the
Joe poker so this next film Folia do is
basically going to be an origin story
for Harley Quinn now it does seem like
it's going to focus on Harley
considerably after all this film is
being described as a romantic musical
from Harley's perspective now when we
last left the Joker he was in the Asylum
so we can assume that Harlan quinzel is
going to be one of the psychiatrists
they are treating him we could also
assume that he's going to Captivate her
in some way and she'll end up falling in
love with him much like what we've seen
before however to make this different
it's going to be in a musical form but
since the first Joker was dark and it
was twisted that's most likely what
we're getting from the sequel which has
fans very curious as to how they are
going to actually pull off this musical
format for the second film now as far as
teasers go don't expect a teaser trailer
or anything like that anytime soon Joker
folie adieu comes out October 4th of
2024 and it is going to be an elseworld
movie meaning James Gunn has deemed
anything outside of the connected DC
Universe and elseworld film Batman and
the second Batman film that is coming is
also a part of the else World movies
however do not get this confused the
else World projects are not connected to
each other as far as we know so far but
we have over a year and a half to go
until the release of Joker Folia do so
don't expect a teaser anytime soon but
appreciate what we got here we could
probably expect some more to come from
Todd Phillips who released this who is
the director of the film so as things
get going and they start and they start
doing some photography hopefully he'll
give us a little bit more so in the
meantime let me know what you think
about our first look at Joker Foley Adu
in our first look at Lady Gaga as Harley
Quinn leave your thoughts down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to stay up to date on the
latest DCU news you can always follow us
on Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf
wolf